bonjour stéphanie gibeau
merci et merci à toi merci à vous d'être
en direct avec nous ce matin sur air
france pour parler de cet appel des
états unis pour faire annuler l
interdiction d'extradition qui avait été
édictée par la cour de justice
britannique pourquoi cet acharnement cet
acharnement américains alors que joe
biden est au pouvoir les choses n'ont
pas changé
non pas de journalistes vient de résumer
parfaitement la situation c'est à dire
que c'est gilles à de la survie de nos
démocraties puisque les enjeux sont
quand même extraordinaire on a un
journaliste qui a un qui n'a fait que
son travail de journalisme qui est
imprimé des informations ou qui a
transmis des informations dont
d'ailleurs beaucoup de médias à
l'international se sont servis et qui
est puni pour avoir fait son métier de
journaliste qui est l'un des seuls 1
appliquée justement la charte de munich
qui avait été signé il ya presque 50 ans
pour que justement les choses soient
plus comme elle l'avait été il ya 80 ans
aurait qu'on ait un journalisme qui se
font un journalisme indépendant et
journalisme libre est en fait il est
puni pour ça donc on a vraiment un
problème sur l'un sur huit de nos
démocraties vous savez très bien que si
tu lui n'a songé été extradé vers les
états unis comme vient de le dire à
l'instant c'était la mort east reportage
étant donné l'état de santé dans lequel
il est certain qu il va vers une mort
assurée son sens sans parler des 150
années de prison les peaux pour laquelle
pourrait pas survivre donc déjà ça ça
c'est monstrueux et j'aime ans un
précédent et puis on sait que cette
histoire a été montée de toutes pièces
des états unis puisque vous avez dû
entendre récemment le le
l'histoire du fameux témoin clé
islandais qui en fait est l'élément
central haussier américain et qui a
admis avoir menti des traces arrange
pour avoir l'immunité des états unis
c'est vraiment la corruption totale du
système
justice américains qui collaborent avec
des individus qui sont pas des gens qui
sont pas des gens bien enfin dont on
sait qu'ils sont des criminels ouais je
viens là singes dont la vie est en
danger c'est ce qu'a fait valoir la juge
britannique pour empêcher cette
extradition en janvier basé sur des
risques de suicide ils risquent plus
julian assange avait que cette histoire
de cia qui qui qui aurait fomenté des
plans pour l'enlever voir l'assassiner
ça reste évidemment des plans qui n'ont
pas été mis à exécution apparemment mais
est ce que c'est un risque réel
également pour julian assange en cas
d'extradition
j'essaie d'aider expert psychiatre parle
de justement la situation de détresse
psychologique dans laquelle dans
laquelle il se trouve depuis 10 ans fin
imaginez quand même il est enfermé
depuis depuis une décennie donc ça crée
forcément des troubles des troubles des
troubles énorme donc ça ajoute un tout
ce que tout ce que je viens de dire
votre votre votre confrère est tout ce
qu on discute depuis depuis cinq minutes
c'est à dire que tout repose d'accéder
grâce aux expertises tout repose sur ce
fameux rapport d'expertisé qui va être
contestée par les états unis
voilà c'est bien la problématique
justement et pourtant et pourtant
j'imagine que vous le connaissez julian
assange il ya des témoignages qui
confirment évidemment son état de santé
écoutez on l'a tous vu fin quand ce
qu'ils te connaissent l'une l'an tous vu
enfermé dans l'ambassade d'équateur ou
bien évidemment les conditions étaient
pas celle qui vit depuis deux ans mais
qui était déjà celle de d'impressionner
de quelqu'un enfermés qu'ils pouvaient
pas voir la lumière du soleil
donc si vous voulez comment comment est
ce que vous voulez que nos démocraties
puisse se sortir de cela grandit
aujourd'hui assange est un symbole il
est une symbolique pour beaucoup de gens
partout dans le monde qui vont aller
chercher
sa liberté si nos dirigeants ne le font
pas voyez nous la france pays des droits
de l'homme on brille par notre silence
par notre indifférence c'est juste
tellement édifiant de voir à quel point
nos gouvernants quelles que soient leurs
tendances politiques se servent tous
deux de cette histoire pour justement se
murer dans un silence qui est confondant
on voit bien qu'ils sont pas du tout là
pour servir les citoyens pas là du tout
pour servir la liberté de la presse
l'indépendance la liberté de parole donc
la justice britannique
parce qu'elle décidera dans l'est dans
les semaines qui viennent mais il est
évident que ciel si elle se positionner
contre assange
pour l'extradition vers les états unis
il est fort possible tout bascule
beaucoup donné et le jour où ça
basculera
retrouveront tous face aux citoyens qui
sont quand même beaucoup plus nombreux
on le voit par ce qui se passe en italie
en ce moment où ses rassemblements en
grande bretagne il ya des français sont
partis hier et
on peux les saluer parce que c'est des
cons pas qu'elles sont un
qui sont d'une violence inouïe on est
louis une injustice quand que l'on
ressent autant votre émotion et
stéphanie gibeau l'ultime recours ce
serait quoi ce serait une grâce
présidentielle américaine
oui couple est aussi une décision de la
justice britannique qui irait dans le
sens
des droits de l'homme enfin c'est c'est
juste édifiant d'arriver à des
situations où nous l'europe on donne des
leçons de morale à tout le monde en
terme en termes de droits de l'homme et
les droits de l'homme n'existe
absolument plus les droits de l'homme
sont au service de gouvernants et de
multinationales qui sont plus puissantes
que nos états donc nous sommes politique
par définition au bény ça c'est à ces
multinationales ces entreprises à ces
deux banques qui sont bien plus
puissantes que les que les états et puis
on a des fonctionnaires
des hauts fonctionnaires qui appelle en
anglais we're working drôle c'est à dire
qu'ils servent les penny et après qu'ils
sont au service de ces puissances
d'argent et qui bien évidemment ne sont
absolument pas l'un pour pour défendre
les intérêts et les intérêts des
citoyens
donc
peut-être ils ne sont pas encore rendus
compte nos dirigeants que le monde est
en train de changer le monde est en
train de basculer il ya une prise de
conscience des allées génération y et z
qui commence à dire qu'ils veulent plus
de ce monde et c'est pour ça qu'on peut
remercier tous ceux qui se mobilisent de
par le monde pour un singe parce qu'en
fait il est la symbolique de ce monde
qui est en train justement de
s'effondrer
merci beaucoup stéphanie et gibeau pour
votre témoignage le président mâcon qui
doit rencontrer joe biden après demain
peut-être en glissera-t-il un mot peu
probable merci beaucoup en tout cas pour
votre mairie écrivain il ya ce matin en
direct sur arte france